Hi.
How is everybody?
The toxic Google.
My name is such Egan.
Thanks for being here.
I don't,
I don't think these guys need any introduction,
but we'll still venture to give one anyway.
It's my immediate right is John Hillcoat.
I do need an introduction.
All right.
We'll do our best over in four.
Yeah.
Okay.
He's an Australian award winning award winning film director Music Video
Director and screenwriter.
Yeah.
A lot of great memories at this point.
Wikipedia.
Lay it to me.
Oh,
I'm sorry.
Fair.
I know a,
is it a lot of good movies by now?
Uh,
one of them you guys might have seen the road,
uh,
the film adaptation of the road by Cormac Mccarthy teacher where you go.
Yeah.
And then to my further right men who probably needs no introduction to either,
but Aaron Paul who stole our hearts and our nerves.
It's Jesse Pinkman on breaking bad.
Oh,
also one,
a lot of awards for that.
What a lot of best supporting actor awards.
And we're here today to talk about their new heist thriller.
Triple nine out tomorrow.
Exciting stuff.
What can we see it guys?
Thank you.
Already.
Thank all right.
So you guys be doing the rounds.
This is stop number 430 on the tour.
We talked about that.
Put you on the spot.
What's the,
what's the best question you've been asked about the film so far?
I've got it.
Uh,
oh,
I think I was asked.
Um,
what does Norman Rita's smell like?
I think we're all curious to know more about that as well.
Yeah.
Uh,
oh man.
Yeah.
Do you remember what Norman smells like?
No.
I make a point of not.
All right.
We'll set smelling your actors.
Uh,
yeah.
Let's start with the basics then.
I guess we'll have better questions for you guys on this one.
Okay.
So talk about how'd you get involved with the film?
How'd you first hear about it?
Why this picture?
How'd you guys get involved?
Well,
I heard about the,
uh,
I got the script.
Uh,
it's a first time script writer,
um,
ex marine guy who talked to a friend of his,
who was a call that told him about a triple nine and neither one of us had heard
about it.
Does anyone know about a triple nine?
No.
They got it.
There you go.
That's how it started.
So triple nine,
it's a police code for officer down and,
uh,
you know,
it's an unwritten law that,
uh,
all the cops will go to that destination if they hear it.
And a contemporary crime thriller,
I've been itching to do something temporary about like a slice of life and you
know,
the,
the streets today.
So this was the opportunity and,
uh,
yeah,
you're,
I mean,
yeah,
the,
uh,
this was placed in front of me out of nowhere.
I,
I saw that John Hillcoat was even working on his next project.
And I mean,
I think that's really why we got such an incredible,
incredible cast and jump on board.
Uh,
he doesn't do all that many movies,
but you know,
the ones that he does do is going to be just a brutal gripping story,
um,
in a very human way.
And,
uh,
and yeah,
I read the script and I thought it was incredible.
And so,
um,
I had to jump at the opportunity ensemble cast
just to name a few you've heard over and over.
Casey Affleck,
Woody Harrelson,
Kate Winslet,
Anthony Mackie,
yourself,
just just to name a few.
What was it like to work with that much talent all in one place?
Uh,
incredible,
terrifying,
you know,
as a,
an embarrassment of riches.
You know,
I've,
I've been a huge fan of most of these cast members for a very long time and,
uh,
some of them being a dear friends of mine,
and so it was nice to go to work and,
you know,
work with people that you really look up to and work with this guy.
And,
um,
yeah,
it was great.
Very cool.
Yeah.
Well,
I,
I was,
yeah,
totally spoiled rotten with,
uh,
these guys could,
they're all very committed,
very,
um,
top of the game,
uh,
actors that,
are attracted to.
Uh,
you know,
when you mentioned humanity that that was the thing is that even a world is grim
and,
and Knarley is,
you know,
crime.
It actually,
you know,
behind all these people are,
are the people.
So,
um,
so these actors like eight,
10 parts,
uh,
main characters,
um,
needed a real richness,
you know,
to uh,
cover that big,
it's like a sea of or a soup of human,
um,
kind of,
uh,
floors in your character is in some ways I think the most conflicted in the
film,
not to give anything away.
Um,
we see a lot of conflict.
Uh,
those ones you're
always dealing with conflict.
Okay.
Yeah.
Did you,
did you struggle to figure out how to act as character?
Was it similar to stuff you've done before?
What was it like?
I mean,
you know,
I,
I always tend to gravitate towards characters with conflict.
I love playing,
uh,
the darker,
grittier side of things.
Um,
I think it's very honest to the real life.
uh,
would,
before we jumped into shooting this project,
John is very important to him that we had as much information to us at our
fingertips.
And so he,
US endless amounts of information and homework to study up on.
And
Oh,
from Google,
often Google.
Yeah.
Uh,
spent,
spent some time with the LAPD,
did some ride alongs.
Um,
you know,
this is just a side of the world that I am not used to,
but it is acting,
you know,
it's absolutely happening every single day.
Um,
and it's,
uh,
it's crazy,
but,
you know,
so doing the ride alongs
pairing,
did anything really surprise you?
Something you,
which weren't prepared for it and think through?
Uh,
well,
you know,
we,
uh,
we pulled over this guy,
um,
and as we were pulling him over,
they told me that he already had two strikes on his record.
Uh,
third one,
he'd be in prison forever.
Uh,
and this was in fact his third strike,
uh,
because big girl in his front seat was just shot.
Um,
in the backseat was his mom.
Uh,
he had tattoos all over his face.
Um,
they pulled him out of the car,
he had a gun on him with a serial number scratched off.
Um,
but you know,
sitting in this car and going into this world and seeing these young kids on
their bikes,
and they just get a glimpse of a cop car,
they run away from the cops there.
The cops are,
uh,
their enemy,
you know,
but you see these young kids and that's all they know.
And so it's,
she has really humanizes their world,
you know,
cause they don't really have a choice.
They have to side with a gang.
Um,
otherwise they get left behind or got shot in a corner and you really,
you actually,
I mean,
you,
you feel for them and then you see these gang members,
they're just grown up kids and this is all they know.
And so it's,
um,
know it's just,
it's crazy and you're getting a peek behind the,
you know,
we love her curtain per say,
at their world.
Um,
but yeah,
it was,
uh,
it was unreal.
Thank you for that.
I think that the humanity of the characters we meet,
there's a lot of characters in the film and that humanity really kind of comes
through.
Did you have experiences in your own life that sort of led you to wanting to
tell that kind of a story?
Uh,
yeah.
I mean,
I came to America at a very young age and was kind of throwing as a young child,
um,
uh,
new haven,
Connecticut.
And the late sixties was everything was kicking off.
Um,
I used to regularly,
I've found out recently that my mother told me that she used to have me baby sat
by the Black Panthers at their headquarters.
They dropped me off there regularly.
But I remember absorbing at a young age,
the turmoil of that age,
you know,
with the civil rights,
antiwar movement and all those leaders were assassinated in a very short time.
And then the media,
there was no filter.
You know,
there's,
uh,
the Vietnam War was the most publicized,
a unfiltered war in history.
So as a young kid seeing all this and the adult world,
uh,
that,
that did affect me.
And then I,
you know,
started through the seventies and eighties,
looking at all the great American genre films and,
uh,
seeing those worlds in acted.
Um,
but it was yeah,
wanting to get that kind of,
um,
a realism and immersement into this other world,
you know,
go back to the cash briefly.
Was there anybody in the cast,
it's surprised you,
anybody that was just really funny point pranks or just kind of just surprised
you?
I guess having never worked with either of them before.
Well,
we were just talking about earlier,
woody,
woody Harrelson entrance is that,
this is like first,
uh,
seen first time onset,
very first take.
And he pulls up his,
driving his car at high speed.
He jumps the curb,
crashes into a tree,
uh,
smashes his head against the,
thing and gets out of the car with and goes up to Casey and plays the entire
scene.
Two pages without missing a beat while this giant Welt is growing.
And did he give you guys rehearsed it right?
And they said,
well,
there's no reason really coming that hot.
So maybe just
not push that hard on the gas pedal and he's like,
okay,
and then he does this,
which is so woody,
you know?
Yeah.
So it's the tone I guess.
Right.
It right off the bat.
Absolutely.
Fantastic.
A couple of questions for you,
which is about the style drone.
Uh,
a bunch of us watched the film last night and we're talking about afterwards.
One of my friends mentioned,
uh,
okay,
spoiler alert.
There's a lot of,
a lot of shooting in this movie
film with shooting thought,
right.
And,
uh,
use the phrase animating inanimate that we get a lot of first person shooter.
Uh,
we see a vantage point of either the victim or the shooter in a very unique way.
Could you talk about the way you tried to stylize the action in the film?
Oh,
um,
uh,
that's great.
People pick up on that.
Um,
but I liked change.
Yeah.
Um,
yeah,
changing the perspective because,
uh,
violence,
having seen real violence and,
and being very influenced by the history and storytelling in America of and seen
film maker is great.
Filmmakers tackle this subject to me.
Um,
it's always,
there's an element of chaos and unpredictability.
And I think too,
when you're staging action to change that perspective really helps capture that
feeling of uncertainty and,
um,
uh,
yeah.
Rather than,
um,
uh,
keeping one prospective on it.
Fantastic.
Things that make sense.
Did that make sense?
I bet it was great.
What about colors?
I wanted to ask about colors as well.
I know that I am different directors who makers care about color differently.
I guess red is obviously a big movie,
you know,
it's on the film poster.
Yeah.
So,
so should we look out for other colors in addition to read what you're trying to
do with red?
Anything about color?
Well,
that was a conscious choice of,
uh,
because we were shooting in Atlanta in the summer time and we,
we all want to,
to make this genre of fresh again and some way and make it,
keep it a gritty reality.
So,
um,
I did notice the west coast and the east coast when it comes to cops and crime
are always,
uh,
dominated by blue.
Um,
and even even Michael Mann's heat is dominated by blue.
amazing film,
but we,
so there was a conscious choice to,
well,
we're in Atlanta with the hot heat and I wanted to uh,
get that kind of richness of and reds a very,
uh,
emotional color and very vivid and I think it suits the themes,
change a lot of the colors on the cars.
Yeah.
The actual police lights as much as we could.
We,
so we got rid of,
I see a fair bit of blue in this room,
but normally I would be removing,
you know,
like
get rid of your shirt,
give you colors.
We noticed gold actually comes up once or twice as well.
Are there other colors that you were going forward?
Just read.
I was looking at the Google color scheme.
It's a good way to do it.
Yeah,
I like that.
Okay.
No,
we were,
we chose to go with those,
uh,
more,
um,
warmer,
uh,
kind of emotionally more intense colors.
Sure.
To intensify.
It's very,
it's like,
as Aaron often describes it when you,
you know,
there's a lot of adrenaline and energy in the film,
so it kind of,
that's all part of it.
I think the color,
the richness of the color,
we'll then also in reaction to the road,
you mentioned the road,
I was itching to do something with more richness and very well it gets
communicated through and through.
Um,
so what was it,
what was the most challenging part of the filmmaking process for either of you?
Working with us?
Working together was a big dog,
kind of a nightmare.
It was great.
I mean,
um,
I think that the,
the heist was the highlight for me,
um,
just to,
at the beginning of the movie,
uh,
we're trying to,
you know,
rob a bank and just putting on a mask and running inside of a bank with a gun
was amazing.
Um,
and I've made all these guys try it out,
try and do it and do I really do math and to feel what it's really like.
Yeah,
yeah.
Which was grades.
Um,
but yeah,
so,
you know,
and then getting in the car,
I was,
uh,
I'm the get away driver,
um,
and doing that high speed chase was just fantastic.
Is there any other difficult scenes?
Are you just cold?
Well,
probably pretty difficult,
a favorite scene that we know what Erin's is now,
but one of my favorites,
he did remind me of,
uh,
one of my favorites is with Tewa tell Acha for amazing,
very forceful,
powerful actor in the car.
And physically he'd been training with Navy seals for a month and months and
months and he let's,
uh,
well he gets a little angry at that.
He let this guy
aggression out on,
on me and if it's scripted that
he throws a punch,
that means he's just going to beat the shit out of you.
And uh,
he doesn't hold back anything and um,
and it was great.
I mean definitely know it comes across on screen,
but yeah,
anytime they yelled action I was truly terrified.
Yeah.
What about just generally taking a step back from my last question is how'd you
get where you are now?
How'd you guys get into film,
into acting,
into directing?
Anything about that story that you want to share?
Uh,
you know,
I've been acting professionally for a long time.
I moved to la at 17,
graduated high school a year early.
Um,
I don't know if this is always loved the,
I loved it.
You know,
like I said before,
like cops and robbers,
I think all of us boys are,
most of us did that.
It was something to girls to that as well.
Growing up a make believe,
pretend.
Um,
I've always been such a huge fan of,
of film.
Um,
yeah,
that's really cool.
But you don't,
uh,
well similar it just that,
that kind of being immersed in other worlds.
It's like a passport into all these other worlds where we get to go.
And you work like this film we were working with a lot of um,
ex gang members,
gang unit people and very closely so you,
you kind of,
whatever world you go into,
you,
you know,
you really engage with it.
And it's,
so for me that kind of,
um,
passport to all these places was very enticing.
But I got,
I actually got into it through music and music videos way back in the day,
remember those days anyway.
But yeah.
Cool.
And through that,
thank you.
Thank you guys.
I know we've got some questions in the audience.
There's a mic right there for,
for day step on up.
Thanks so much for coming.
Aaron.
I'm a huge fan of your work.
I think.
I think you're one of the most underrated actors in Hollywood.
Oh,
I love you.
We're about
to die happy.
Oh,
so you're really well known,
obviously for breaking bad and now you're moving into movies.
Do you find,
uh,
challenging to shed that character that people know you so well for and turn
into a different person that they don't recognize you as Jesse from breaking
bad,
but as a brand new character?
Yeah,
I mean,
I think a lot of,
you know,
a lot of people,
most people that know my work,
they know me as,
you know,
Jesse Pinkman.
Yeah.
Um,
uh,
on a daily basis I get called a bitch.
It's great.
It was stride.
It was,
uh,
a beautiful show,
beautifully written character,
and I feel very honored,
blessed to have been able to,
uh,
to play that guy.
And so it's all about,
you know,
trying to mix it up,
do something a little different.
You know,
when this came my way,
I get offered drug addict roles all the time.
Wait,
is the instant answer,
quick answer is,
you know,
no,
it's a,
you know,
strong,
solid pass.
Um,
but when this came my way,
it was impossible to ignore John l code.
It's impossible to ignore this story.
You know,
granted,
when I was reading the script and I seen this character picking up a pipe
and
why?
But I had to say yes,
you know,
and so this,
this role is probably the most similar.
I mean,
I think the similarity is just,
you know,
they both have a,
uh,
an addiction to drugs,
along the other thing is,
but yeah,
so it's just about changing it up,
mixing it up.
So hopefully people will,
uh,
see other characters in inmate.
Okay.
Awesome.
Thank you.
And your wife have the most adorable relationship.
She the best.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate that.
And I,
I apologize that I called,
uh,
and bitch
all the time.
Yeah,
yeah.
Act better,
bitch.
I'm trying my best man.
Um,
but yeah.
All right.
John is sexually question for you.
And I have to be honest,
I have not seen the movie,
but I have watched the trailer,
the Red van trailers weekend this weekend and go check it out or be there.
And I'm curious from your perspective in making a movie like this that's really
dark and gritty kind of,
you know,
similar to the road and kind of has that like you think a heat or Scicaro and
kind of the cops and robbers,
those types of movies.
How do you make a movie that has that look and feel compared to a more
traditional,
you know,
not campy but you know,
kind of a cops and robbers bank robber movie that doesn't have that same gritty
dark feel to it by I think by research is probably the key to making that
different Taishan and grounding it.
In reality.
I'm a big fan of reality.
Even if you are doing a film in the future or in the past.
Um,
I think he want,
uh,
or at least I do as a an audience member.
I love that kind of,
um,
detail.
So details and other research detail.
Um,
I look even science fiction.
You know,
I,
I love,
um,
when,
when there's that kind of,
uh,
you know,
you,
if I was to do a science fiction,
I would go to NASA and I would get them involved and,
or physicists involved too,
to get some hard science in there.
Um,
because I think it always helps create that world.
And I think for the actors,
you know,
who are the key to all bringing this to life and actually have that incredible
pressure to in the moment to make it feel real.
Um,
I think it helps that,
you know,
if that world,
if they're touching some kind of reality for them.
Um,
I think,
I hope,
um,
but yeah,
so thank you.
That's,
yeah.
Thank you.
Question for John about the music.
Uh,
I saw it last night and there was the creepiest version of,
um,
what is it,
this little piggy at the end that I've ever heard.
I just want her to unwell.
That's actually Cypress hills.
Cypress Hill has a,
a great,
uh,
classic track from a cold pigs about actually corrupt police corruption.
Um,
so we,
you know,
given the themes of this film,
we thought it was appropriate and adequate swirls.
Uh,
Claudia sign his wife,
Leo,
um,
his brother,
they basically,
uh,
worked very closely and really did an amazing remix of that.
I think I'm so good.
How did you kind of,
did you have to lay down the like,
music
video element of it to not,
you know,
you don't want to have like,
oh,
this featuring the song here now,
you know,
find that really distracting and movies where it's just like someone's playlist.
Um,
yeah.
And,
and um,
I like that kind of,
again,
I keep coming,
I immersive is a word probably overused,
but that,
um,
uh,
thing of where there's sort of the right balance of,
you know,
if their source music or score.
Um,
I think music is greatly under valued a lot in,
in films,
in terms of,
um,
uh,
certainly on the finance here,
production side,
uh,
a lot of,
um,
producers and finances and,
and people in the,
you know,
the studios and stuff have,
have,
uh,
often forget the power of scores and,
and what sound,
you know,
because we're so visually oriented and we all look at story and performance and,
and all that stuff and often we forget the power of sound that
I have.
Kind of a general question about,
um,
you know,
the types of films and TV shows that you've been in or like obviously very heavy
topics.
So you're dealing with gang violence,
drug addiction,
you know,
police corruption,
potentially,
things like that.
How do you feel like when you're immersing yourself so heavily and these really
heavy topics that are,
you know,
serious problems in America and across the world,
gun control,
walking away from something like that,
after you've completed the film,
does it really affect you and do you feel like going back to those issues and
trying to find ways to help situations like that?
But it's like,
you know,
you're especially for breaking bad.
I mean,
when you're working on something for such a long period of time where,
you know,
crystal Meth,
drug addiction in America,
it's like a serious thing that affects people's livelihood and family and all
that kind of stuff.
That's
what I think is so great about breaking bad.
Um,
before the show came out,
like shame on AMC Shaman,
Sony for doing a show that glamorizes the cooking and selling of crystal meth.
Um,
I don't think that showed,
did that at all.
I think,
uh,
showed the brutal,
harsh reality of what that drug does.
And I think it,
I think it actually educated people.
And so I think just making a show like that is doing good.
Um,
you know,
when I first started that show,
I would,
you know,
spend all hours of the night and the darkest alleys of Albuquerque,
New Mexico,
and surround myself with very sketchy,
dangerous people just to kind of put myself in that situation.
Um,
which was probably stupid.
but it helped.
It helped me because that stuff is going on.
And you're right,
uh,
math,
um,
there's a terrible drug and it does take over people and it's not just the
people that are using it.
It's,
you know,
their friends,
their families that are affected by it.
So,
yeah.
And also what was great about that,
he said it's been different waves of,
uh,
drugs that have affected this country.
And,
um,
it Kinda,
it brought up to date a real,
the way that the stakes keep raising.
Like,
you know,
the,
when you think back in the day when prohibition,
it was just like bad,
illegal moonshine,
um,
things have,
uh,
there's been such a huge appetite for drugs,
um,
and that supply and demand,
it's a very tricky equation.
Um,
so I think I'm,
I'm with her and that,
you know,
it's good to for,
um,
film and TV to embrace the reality of what's going on and try and,
you know,
um,
tackle that.
Uh,
how do you walk away from it?
Um,
uh,
that question is kind of just more like,
does it affect you like personally?
A lot when you complete something like that after like really immersing yourself
a lot.
I,
you know,
I get,
uh,
have my guns,
I have my drugs,
I have all my stuff
that's set up,
you know,
so,
so then I know how to use it.
No,
but seriously,
it's a,
I think when you're doing stuff with,
with actual,
uh,
serious,
intention,
I think there's something really positive comes out of it.
I found,
and actually this,
um,
you know,
like I'm in awe of comedy and,
um,
but I also know that comedy is like the darkest,
like the comic geniuses or the darkest people on the planet.
And,
and on a comedy set,
it's the last set you want to be around.
The tension is just off the all scales.
Um,
and I find this,
so it's a balancing act,
I guess is what I'm saying.
There's a lot of,
um,
uh,
but I think,
tackling real things,
whether it's through comedy or through drama,
um,
I think people walk away feeling better for it.
Um,
because it's,
it's kind of a positive action even though you're dealing with a negative.
That was really good.
Yeah.
Wow.
Thank you.
So that's also really tough act to follow.
But I have a question for Aaron.
So you really started to have some great movie roles lately and uh,
you're more better known for your TV roles and,
and just sort of wondering how you want your career to progress in sort of a
character development versus sort of the fast paced life of,
uh,
you know,
movie star.
Uh,
it was just long as I continue to work,
it's always like the main goal,
um,
but just do stuff that,
you know,
I really believe in stories that I believe in,
the characters that I believe in.
Um,
just it's all about the material.
If it's not on the page,
you don't have anything.
So it's all about finding the right stories to tell and then getting the right
directors to kind of hold the reigns to tell that story.
So just,
you know,
working with directors that I look up to,
um,
writers I look up to,
whether that's TV,
film,
I like it all.
He already dropped.
Thanks for being here.
Thank you.
[inaudible].